[Applauso]
immaginiamo per un attimo qualcosa di
completamente assurdo
ad un certo punto della storia una rotta
migratoria millenaria viene
artificialmente interrotta una strada
che per secoli è stata percorsa da
intere popolazioni smette semplicemente
di esistere aggiungiamo a questa storia
un altro elemento di assurdità questo
blocco avviene infatti all'apice di un
conflitto armato che sta costringendo
appunto un'intera popolazione a emigrare
in massa per sfuggire ad uno sterminio
inevitabile quello che i burocrati
perché ti burocrati si tratta che hanno
firmato l'ordine di chiusura
quello che avessero in testa in quel
momento non ci è dato saperlo forse
pensavano che le persone arrivate al
confine facessero dietrofront e
tornassero indietro o che le famiglie
trovatisi improvvisamente separate non
facessero di tutto per riunificarsi con
qualunque mezzo a loro disposizione o
che comunque tutte queste persone
accettassero in silenzio questa
decisione senza nemmeno far spostare la
loro rabbia o la loro frustrazione in
protesta dimostrazioni questo appunto
non lo sapremo mai
e forse non lo capiremo mai però una
cosa è certa sappiamo quello che è
successo realmente
perché questa storia così assurda è una
storia vera la primavera del 2016
ungheria serbia e macedonia decidono
arbitrariamente richiudere i loro
confini in faccia alle migliaia di
persone in fuga dalla siria
interrompendo di fatto la pall cannes
rotte la rotta balcanica un percorso
millenario che collega europa d'asia da
un giorno con l'altro
decine di migliaia di persone rimangono
bloccate in grecia che diventa una terra
di mezzo fra medioriente e nord europa
che in quel momento che già lasciato le
isole aveva la fortuna tra virgolette
ritrovarsi già sul land sulla terraferma
inizia a calcare si lungo i confini
interni della grecia nella speranza di
superare il filo spinato e poter così
proseguire il cammino
ed è proprio qui sul filo spinato
para la grecia dalla macedonia che
inizia la nostra storia a di domani e
domenica un minuscolo paesino di
frontiera con una stazione dei treni
fatiscente e campi agricoli a perdita
d'occhio a poche decine di metri il
confine greco macedone e poi di nuovo
campi e boschi fino all'orizzonte da un
giorno con l'altro questo microscopico
avamposto di frontiera si trasformi in
una gigantesca tendopoli dove più di
15.000 persone vivono nella speranza di
poter attraversare il filo spinato che
le separa da amici e affetti che solo
fino a qualche giorno prima erano
riusciti a passare in questa situazione
di totale immobilità dove il tempo non
passa mai
si iniziano a gettare le basi per
qualcosa di nuovo per un progetto nuovo
un enorme laboratorio sociale a cielo
aperto che fra le altre cose attira a sé
centinaia di persone da tutto il mondo
persone che vogliono fare parte del
progetto politico che si sta costruendo
ai domeni persone che sono curiose o
persone che vogliono partecipare alla
sua costruzione
fra queste persone ovviamente ci sono
anch'io
al di là delle grandi organizzazioni
umanitarie che basano il loro intervento
su pratiche di solidarietà passiva e
assistenzialistica e quindi non
restituisce dignità alle persone un
ruolo chiave lo gioca il grande numero
di attivisti indipendenti che abita nel
campo e che si impegna nella costruzione
di pratiche diverse di pratiche attive
che non passano necessariamente da un
aiuto materiale ma dall impiego di nuovi
linguaggi dall'impiego di modalità
operative diverse che abbattono per una
volta le etichette imposte e anche se
vogliamo inflazionate dai media ma
mettono piuttosto le persone al centro
non ricordo con precisione momento in
cui tutto questo ha iniziato era notte
fonda e ci trovava in una grande tenda
la tenda che di giorno era un ufficio
legale indipendente e di notte era la
nostra casa si discuteva come sempre di
cosa fare il giorno dopo di come portare
avanti il sogno che stavamo costruendo
ai domeni così spesso messo a rischio
dalla stanchezza dalla mancanza di
fiducia e anche dalle autorità che non
erano d'accordo con il nostro progetto e
ci mettevano
bastone fra le ruote ragazzi perché non
facciamo una radio una radio una radio
una radio una stazione radiofonica ma in
che senso una stazione radiofonica
massico le antenne e ripetitori la
mettiamo dentro una tenda
l'accendiamo iniziamo a trasmette ai
domeni 6 domeni facciamo radio domani
facciamo radio domeni prendiamo degli
attivisti prendiamo dei rifugiati
prendiamo pure qualche volontario e
diciamo a trasmettermi sembra una buona
idea
che ne pensate radio la capo dott
radja noborder iniziale proprie
trasmissioni in un campo profughi a 20
chilometri dai domani dopo che
quest'ultimo nel frattempo era stato
spazzato via dalla furia dei bulldozer
della polizia e con esso anche molto del
sogno che stavamo costruendo al suo
interno
ok sono d'accordo sul fatto che farò una
radio pirata all'interno di un campo
profughi è un progetto un po bizzarro e
all'apparenza anche abbastanza inutile
del resto nessuno di noi aveva mai avuto
esperienze radiofoniche rilevanti in
passato quindi non sapevamo né cosa
stavamo facendo
né come lo stavamo facendo inoltre un
progetto del genere in porta con sé una
serie di quesiti ai quali non stavamo
ancora dare risposta per chi la facciamo
questa radio come ci devono ascoltare e
chi ci deve ascoltare non sapendo bene
da che parte cominciare abbiamo
cominciato con tutto un antenna montata
su una canna da pesca trasmetteva sulla
frequenza pirata 90 500 in onde medie
una parabola satellitare puntata verso
il cielo mandava le trasmissione in
diretta su internet e poi un enorme
altoparlante posto al centro del campo
disturbava prepotentemente la quiete
pubblica mandando per ore ed ore
interviste interventi story ma anche
tanta troppa musica inascoltabili a
volumi troppo alti
solo dopo mi sono reso conto che è stata
l'unione di queste tre diverse modalità
di ascolto
costruire la radio come dispositivo
narrante diverso e in quel momento unico
il grande altoparlante oltre che
disturbare le persone le avvicinava alla
radio gli permetteva di capire cosa
stesse succedendo e gli permetteva di
avvicinarsi e di diventare curiose di
rompere il ghiaccio
l'antenna pirata oltre che essere
bellissima da vedere
tra queste norme canna da pesca con le
saldature che spaccavano ogni cinque
minuti
dava un po l'impressione che questa
radio forse di tutti noi e la sua cupola
protettiva che era il raggio d'azione
che poi era qualche chilometro per la
verità ci separava un po da quell europa
e da quelle politiche criminali dalle
quali volevamo sottrarci e poi il fatto
di andare in diretta su internet
costruiva la consapevolezza nelle
persone che le parole almeno quelle
potessero varcare quelle linee
immaginarie che erano diventati
invalicabili del resto il segnale veniva
sparato dritto nello spazio poi tornava
indietro sulla terra investendola tutta
raggiungendo virtualmente tutti gli
abitanti del pianeta
poi non tutti gli abitanti del pianeta
si sintonizzavano però alcuni si attorno
alla radio nasce subito una comunità una
comunità di persone che vogliano farne
parte che vogliano partecipare la
costruzione delle trasmissione dei
contenuti avveniva in silo nun me con di
metodi condivisi ma non esattamente come
una vera propria redazione della radio
ma qualcosa di simile e con il passare
del tempo le persone iniziavano a
trovare il loro ruolo all'interno della
radio c'erano i tecnici c'erano gli
speaker c'erano i traduttori c'erano i
dj c'erano altre dj c'erano soprattutto
dj tecnici ero io
gli altri con tutti dj però tutti
assieme costruiamo costruiamo queste
puntate ai microfoni della radio si
atterrano decine di persone ogni giorno
persone che sentono il bisogno di
condividere qualcosa con il mondo e
vedono nella radio uno strumento
autentico per farlo portano la loro
personalità i loro talenti e la loro
arte
improvvisamente la narrazione del
fenomeno migratorio diventa attiva
autogestita e assolutamente pura
ogni volta che qualcuno prende in mano
il microfono e parla il linguaggio si
rovescia cambia cambiano cambia
continuamente a lot of life battery swan
which ilike particolari e because you
before crucis di e poi disney yes molto
grazie for that but just alla turbata
santa sofia gere microphone is open this
is free space express arabic in english
italia milioni in italia il mario ed
delli santi che implica all'altro that
thank you have all the lovers a bad
place extension e just me già formati
playstation
vecchio station espression in siria
breakdown compilation the mountains
destination in your imagination grazie e
ogni caso e sentendo queste cose che ci
rendiamo conto della potenza di questo
strumento potente per chi lo pratica
perché è costretto a mettersi al centro
e utilizzare solamente la propria voce e
potente per chi lo ascolta che per una
volta riceve un punto di vista diverso
unico e molto più umano radiano border
viene smantellato a metà giugno quando
la polizia irrompe nel campo ne ordina
lo sgombero mentre rifugiati vengono
deportati contro la loro volontà nei
campi militari noi attivisti veniamo
tutti arrestati
però quel punto a quel punto abbiamo
capito che cosa vogliamo fare e abbiamo
anche imparato come farlo ora di una
border diventa un progetto itinerante si
sposta fra italia europa e medio oriente
e tocca tutte quelle situazioni che in
qualche modo hanno a che fare con il
fenomeno dell'immigrazione racconta le
storie le speranze dei migranti africani
che vivono in stato di schiavitù nel sud
del nostro paese o di quelli che fra
ventimiglia e como cercano di superare i
confini a nord sempre del nostro paese e
quando non ci riesco non vengono portati
proprio qua nella città di taranto
racconta di chi pagando l'ennesimo
trafficanti è riuscito a portare alla
sua famiglia a berlino al sicuro
racconta dei rifugiati palestinesi che
vivono in libano per sfuggire alla morsa
israeliana o dei cordì di mosul che
vivono negli enormi campi profughi
iracheni
in un processo totalmente naturale la
creazione la costruzione dei contenuti
inizia decentralizzati non c'è più una
redazione della radio che prende i
furgoni parte monta le antenne trasmette
o meglio quel che lascia ancora ci siamo
ancora noi che abbiamo voglia di farlo
però c'è anche una piattaforma una
piattaforma aperta chiunque abbia voglia
di continuare questa grande opera di
narrazione collettiva da quel 30 maggio
del giugno 2016 quando abbiamo iniziato
a trasmettere
e passato più di un anno ma radio no
border è ancora una realtà viva in
quest'anno di trasmissioni abbiamo
imparato un altro modo di raccontare le
migrazioni raccontandoli attraverso la
voce dei loro involontari protagonisti
abbiamo scoperto che costruendo una
narrazione attiva insieme a loro e non
per loro o con loro insieme a loro
riusciamo in qualche modo a creare un
punto fermo nel loro viaggio così tanto
più legato bisogni materiali e
impellenti abbiamo anche scoperto che
far viaggiare le loro voci attraverso le
nuvole è un modo come un altro di
avvicinarli alle donne e agli uomini che
li aspettano
dall'altra parte di queste linee
immaginarie che sono i confini e finché
ci saranno le loro voci ci sarà qualcuno
di noi che avrà voglia e sarà disposto
ad ascoltarle a trasmetterle ea
conservarne e l'invito per fare ciò è
aperto a tutti grazie
[Applauso]